this is crazy mostly I think we're all
gonna die
[Music]
there is a stranger comes from the sea
Arthur curry also known as be Aquaman
here you can talk to fish Aquaman
he kills from two different worlds he's
half man he's half Atlanta
[Music]
he is the heir to the throne of Atlantis
buddies might became head
I heard about you
[Applause]
when he finds his place with the Justice
League that's when he can really put his
skills to use
[Music]
one of my favorite things to film that's
when I jumped on for that 'mobile cool
moment
I was like can I believe I'm surfing the
babble girl right now we do this
together
[Music]
Oh
just like a bat I dig it
can't say the man
[Music]
honestly I think we're all gonna die so
if you guys didn't catch it that clip at
the beginning is of Aquaman wearing his
new armor in the Aquaman movie after
Justice League they're still finishing
the Aquaman movie right now
Justice League obviously coming out in a
couple weeks they've been done filming
that for a long time now but there is
that ticket giveaway that's going on all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
uh name a new winner at the end of this
but we need to talk about the different
versions of the armor that he wears
throughout the movie there's actually
three different versions that we've seen
him in so far between the promo
materials for Batman V Superman the
initial Aquaman movie stuff and then
this full suit of armor and then
obviously the newest one being that clip
at the beginning of this so if it wasn't
clear there is Atlantis stuff happening
during the Justice League movie but
because it's more about getting the band
together for the first time in the
MacGuffins all about the mother boxes
and one of the mother boxes is in
Atlantis the actual stuff that you see
of it in the movie is really just to get
you hyped up for the Aquaman movie like
that's really well they'll deal with it
and Jason Momoa has been saying a whole
bunch of stuff about the dynamics of his
character how he fits in with the team
in what his character is like when the
Aquaman movie picks up but for the most
part all of the trailers stuff you've
seen of Aquaman between Batman V
Superman and Justice League is is the
beginnings of that character like he
talks about how he can't control his
powers and then there's the idea of him
gaining the Atlantean artifacts in a big
part of the evolution of his character
isn't physically watching him evolve as
his armor gets more badass and he gets
the Trident so starting at the beginning
this is sort of the first version you
saw them during Batman V Superman with
the shoulder piece is a comic book
accurate costume
but the armor that he's wearing in all
of these Justice League scenes actually
belonged to keen at land and many thanks
to Zack Snyder for posting all these
behind-the-scenes images we get a look
here for the Darkseid prequel I'll
explain that in a second but you see
this Atlantean King wearing a crown and
the armor that Aquaman is wearing during
the movie so you're like oh very clearly
Aquaman is just wearing an ancient suit
of armor in my initial take away was
that this is either his father King Oran
or it's at land the original King and I
think the idea is that this prequel
takes place so far in the past that
Aquaman's father wouldn't have been born
at that time so if you don't read comics
Atlanteans do have very long lifespans
but they don't live anywhere nearly as
long as Amazons but even some of the
Amazons in this prequel scene seem like
they're ancient compared to the Amazons
in the Wonder Woman movie they live much
much longer almost timeless but they're
not all gods in the way that Wonder
Woman is a god and war ravage the earth
so the gods created us the Amazons
to influence men's hearts with love and
restore peace to the earth like this
character in the background here with
the bow that actually might be Artemis
who we see during the Wonder Woman movie
but she's much much older at that point
so when you see the Amazons charging the
fields here with all these other
soldiers this just seems like it's
happening thousands of years in the past
and because it's a zack snyder movie and
he tends to have those prequels scenes I
think we're expecting the same treatment
as Batman V Superman where they explain
a little bit of context for what's going
on with Darkseid and the mother boxes
[Music]
we're too late he's here
sorry were ill-equipped to process your
flesh my fries but here in my personal
laboratory I can splice your kryptonian
genetic code we made a new form a super
parrot even in the service of darkseid
so just more evidence that this actually
is king at land and Aquaman is wearing
his ancient armor like he's sort of
acknowledging his heritage during the
Justice League movie and obviously it
looks really badass but by the time we
get to the Aquaman movie which takes
place after Justice League it seems like
he'll be getting a big upgrade in like
all movies you want the heroes to get a
new suit Batman gets a new version of
the suit every single movie why would an
Aquaman also upgrade his armor if he's
going to become king of Atlantis it as
far as Jason Momoa and James Wan have
said they'll address all of the Aquaman
Atlantean politicking and him taking the
throne during the Aquaman movie the
Justice League movie won't really get
into that too much but you do get a
little taste for that when he goes back
to Atlantis to get this armor and get
the Trident but you'll also probably
notice that the statue that he's staring
at underwater here is the same as King
at land in this behind-the-scenes
picture so I know there's been a lot of
talk about scenes being cut out of
Justice League then maybe cutting out
Green Lantern's stuff I think they're
just winnowing the film down to the
brilliant essential stuff so you get a
taste for things that are happening in
Central City like Zack Snyder posted
this scene as they're getting ready for
some Barry Allen moment in the movie but
just let me know in the comments what do
you think of the different versions of
Aquaman's armor in this new version that
they're teasing for the Aquaman movie
they also posted some more behind the
scenes pictures there's some Atlantean
armor but these are King Arms soldier so
a lot of you know that throne of
Atlantis story it'll be Aquaman vs ocean
master for the throne
welcome bastard is Atlantis everything
you dreamed of brother
or in your dream were you on the throne
so I have a reverse flash video that a
lot of you been requesting that will
post tomorrow with my DC TV Q&A so feel
free to leave all your DC questions and
I'll add that to the Q&A video so
congratulations to the newest giveaway
winner Sam please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to rewatch that arrow Batman scene and
you can click here to rewatch that last
big Justice League trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight